hey y'all it's undercat here and this
tight tuesday video we're going to be
starting a new series
on our shiny so a lot of you guys have
haven't asked me to make more videos on
our shiny and like my tidy verse series
i wanted to make a shiny series where it
goes over you know the basics of our
shiny
um which is more catered towards
beginners
um i've already made a few videos on our
shiny such as like flex
dashboard versus china dashboard um
shiny modules
so i'm not gonna really uh mention or
touch those topics since i've already
made a few videos on it
additionally i noticed uh one of the
commenters
wanting me to make a video on like the
golem framework
um and i'd like to do that but after
reading all the documentation
and on the actual development i think
that
golem is too big of a concept for a
single video and it would be better as
its own series so i'm not really going
to touch over
um golem um but i am gonna focusing
uh for this video on uh the actual
filter mechanisms to help you um add
some more interactiveness
in your dashboard so right now
i have this simple little um shiny
dashboard since
that's my preferred framework and uh
let's actually run the app and show you
guys
what it is so i created this one page
which will show
basically all of the available filters
that you can use in our shiny
there are a few things that i removed
just because they were kind of redundant
but
these are the main type of filters we're
gonna use
uh when we're gonna develop a dashboard
so right here it's like a little
box um some radio buttons a little
select input
um a numeric input where you can like
type a number or kind of like uh
click on it a text input so we can type
stuff
i'm a little slider a date
a date range and a file input
so for me when i was actually looking at
our shiny i noticed that you know
a lot of these filters that we are that
are available
aren't really used a lot so for for
example this type of checkbox
it's not something that i really see a
lot in a dashboard but if you're going
to create your own little like survey
you know that could be really helpful um
as for file input
i'm actually going to do that for our
next video over action buttons and file
handling so
uploading being able to upload a file
and also being able to download a file
from your shiny dashboard instead i
figured that i would make a video
basically showing up how to use you know
common filters that we'd actually
typically see
in a shiny dashboard um and in that case
we're going to use the
select filter or the kind of the
drop-down filter a slider filter
a little date filter so like after date
before date and then also a date range
filter
so the so we're going to be using this
one
on this one this one and that one
okay so what's kind of cool about this
dashboard is you can see
all the examples of the actual filters
we have our checkbox radio buttons etc
and then we also have our actual plots
right here for the
separate uh tab so when i'm actually
building a dashboard and i'm trying to
envision how i'm going to use the
interactiveness for each
chart i generally will do some
pre-filtering
as like a little hard-coded or fixed
variable
so for the select example um since it's
going to be a drop down
we're probably going to select you know
the three species and filter that
so right now i already have the species
filtered to setosa
which is pretty useful but let's start
actually creating
our filtering so this right here is
where we're going to put it
create a little box and in this case
since we're going to use the
select input or the select example we're
just going to type in the
select input our input id
will always be like i don't know i
always call it like v select
our label will be species
right and then we can choose our choices
so for our choices we know that we're
going to be using the iris example
so if you look at right here iris we
have all these things and we have our
species right there
one way that we can kind of isolate the
species is we can do
a like a like a unique
and then iris uh species
and it'll show us right here you know
the species that
we wanted to have as our available
choices so i'm just gonna put that right
there
and then finally what we can do is type
in our selected variable so this is like
our pre-selected variable
and we're just going to say setosa
additionally you have another option
with the select
input so if we go right here
we can see we have multiple um in this
case it doesn't really make any sense
that we
want to do multiple um and then you have
like a select ties which i'm actually
not very
familiar with that i think that's just i
guess it's just a ui thing
so i'm good with just that um and then
also what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna make
the width
of the box uh six
okay so let's run that let's see our
filter
and then we can see right here we have
our three species
okay um so let's actually use this
filter
and to reuse filters what we want to
realize is that
this inner ui is our input so this
variable that we called it our input id
is call is going to be called v select
okay and what we can do is basically
replace
where our variable is going to be so in
this case since
v select is going to represent a species
we can replace our
you know hard-coded setosa with input
v select right
and then we can just run the app
and if we change it it should be versa
color right so change that
virginica setosa etc
okay so that's basically how we do it
right there um there are definitely
definitely some ways we can
uh change it so instead of just
filtering to that specific species
we'd also say like we could do like a
mutate or like a little flag
um and stuff like that um i think we
could probably even do a
subtitle right and paste in the input
v select
oops and i think it should put the uh
um yeah the the species so we can have
that
right there too if we were you know to
make it a little bit more custom and
then remove the species right there
but um as you can see filtering with the
general select inputs is very
straightforward
um definitely a good little trick is
using the unique
iris and then the little dollar sign to
select the column
so it's way less code you don't have to
use pipes um
which makes it a little bit cleaner okay
so let's do our next example which will
be the
slider example and with the slider
example we're going to be using our
slider
input so slider inputs
i'm just going to call it the slider
label will be
let's see what we're going to call it so
in the slider example
i guess i'm just saying um we're going
to be finding
uh we're going to be plotting out um the
flowers with
a sepal length less than the the
variable
we're just going to call this uh sepal
length
it's simple length okay
and then what we have are some options
which will be min
is equal and then we'll have a little
max
and then our value which would be one
zero
and our step which would be zero and
then we'll say our width is four
and in this case we're actually going to
change it so in this case i want to do
iris sepal length
and then max iris sepal length
our value let's just say i don't know
the median
and our step will be i don't know like
0.5
okay let's run it
and we can see we have our little sequel
length right there
and we can change it okay so that's good
and dandy
um again and with our v slider variable
we kind of go over here and then type in
our input
v slider save it
right and then we can see how we have
our sepal length right there
and we change it to like 4.3 we can see
it's filtering out so it's only showing
setosa
open it back up etc yeah
pretty cool pretty quick way to uh
um add some functionality to your chart
okay so the next a few
filterings is some date filters and i
think date filters
are probably something that you would
use more often
so let's actually get into it and
there's two types of date filters
a a simple date input which will just
show
a single date and then a date range
input which is going to be like a start
and an end date so again you know date
input
um it's got just it's just one simple
date date range input you're going to
give it a range of stuff
and we'll see how we can call date range
input and how it differs from the
original
date input so let's actually do it
um so we'll say date input and we'll
call it v
date our label will be i guess
date and our value will be something
where we kind of need to figure out what
our value should be
in that case we want to look at the
actual charts that we're looking at
which is the economics data set if we
actually look at the economics data set
you know it's just doing it by each uh
by a year and month
so it's a bunch of monthly data um
in this case you know since it's saying
1980 uh
the beginning of the 80s we'll just do
that first
so as dot date just oops
copy that in
and um that's basically it for that uh
we actually
do some min so min is equal to you know
it's
we can just say uh 1900
1900 01.01 and their max will be
uh let's say a 20 20
uh 2020 as dot
date 120 i want a one
yep and then we'll actually add our
width in which will be
uh was it six yeah [ __ ] six
gotta change that back to six we'll run
that
and we can see we have our little dates
you can select that
what's cool is you can kind of go into
the month and then also to the years
so as you can see it's pretty
interesting you also i think can
type in stuff right that
but let's actually start putting in our
uh
[Music]
our date so right here we'll just say
input
v date right and nothing crazy really
happened
uh right there so right now it's after
the 80s and then we can change it say um
let's do
um i don't know the 90s right there and
you can see it fills us to the 90s
okay um i think you can still do you can
also do it as
the uh um um the way we were doing as
like more of a dynamic approach so if we
want to
say let's let's actually try this out
because i'm pretty sure it'll work but
you never know let me uh men
economics date
yeah and then we can say as dot date men
men economics date
yeah sure so maybe we could actually
make this a little bit more
um you know a little bit more
programmatic let's just do that
and now let's just do uh that
x
right so then we still have it
cool okay
so we have our our date uh filter
and now let's actually do the date range
filter
the box um date range
inputs we'll say v date range
label will be eight
range okay
our start um we'll just uh yeah let's
let's just copy that in you know we'll
do a min
we'll put this thing in there
and just replace this with start
and end i think that should be it and
then we gotta put a little comma
um and yeah so we have that start and
uh yeah let's run that
see if that works and we have our
date filter
cool and i need to check yeah min is
that
okay so now let's actually use our date
range filter and there's a little
thing that's a little bit more
interesting with the date range
is that when we do input
date range also we're going to do like a
input date range um we need to figure
out like which ones to start and which
one's the
end in this case the start will be uh
the uh or the min value or the start
values of the first
item and then the end end value is the
um
the second item let's run that
right so 1967 in this case let's do uh
uh let's do uh let's do like the 1980s
january first we have that
in this case you know maybe we want to
just do a short little time series
analysis of like
um you know the 90s to right
so we have right here um that little
filtering option
cool and yeah
so that's it kind of for the basic
filters um
a lot of times what you want to do is
kind of
program the data understand your min and
max um obviously with the date ranges it
it
it matters more on the context of the
problem
and then also having the steps and stuff
like that um you know you can do
um some filtering or some uh some uh
um programming so you're like you know
the max minus min divided by
10 and round that um stuff like that but
um all in all uh using filters just
understanding you know what to put into
using some
you know base r functions and calling on
the specific column
makes the code look a little bit easier
and something that i
um you know i i kind of had problems
with because i was so stuck in the idea
that everything needs to be in a
tight verse format when in reality this
stuff this nested stuff
makes it look a little bit cleaner when
you're writing
a dashboard or developing dashboard
so let's see the final dashboard right
here are all our filters
and then here are our
original fields that we have now and we
can change that
and obviously now we can add these
filters together
um right so we if we want to add
um we can have multiple uh different
types of filters
for each plot um they go through the
entire dashboard so they're available
for the entire dashboard so it's nothing
there's no real rules against it as long
as they meet the same data types
additionally um your actual date inputs
they don't have to be
inside that little page you can put them
in the sidebar too as well
you can kind of put them anywhere um
stuff like that
uh one of the things that we would
probably want to think about is if we
are going to different pages
we would probably want different types
of filters right um and that's where we
can go into more
dynamic dash sidebars and that will be
for the next video where i'm going to be
focusing more on
you know using file handling
using action buttons and
dynamic variables and also having
dynamics type our options so
um it's definitely less filter heavy and
more on
you know how to add a little bit more
interactiveness a little bit more uh
um advanced stuff um to add a little bit
more um
detail into your dashboard and make it a
little bit more customizable
so i hope you enjoyed this video i know
it's pretty quick but i think this is
pretty simple
um as long as you kind of get a brief
example of all the
ways to use the dashboard slider inputs
and stuff like that so i'll see you guys
next time and tidy on